je trouve qu'on est peut-être un peu
trop
transparent et que je l'ai vécu moi
aussi en Corse vous savez encore c'était
très simple hein quand on narrivait pas
à interpeller quelqu'un de la
criminalité organisée qui partait en
fuite qui se mettait en fuite et cetera
il revenait au bout de il se rendait au
bout de une semaine ou 15 jours sauf que
comme on avait procédé son avocat avait
eu accès au dossier il a le droit hein
et du coup il préparait sa défense et et
d'ailleurs nous attaquer souvent déjà
sur les premières constatations qui nous
avent permis de faire ça hein et et le
début de la garde à vue était déjà
compliqué hein puisque ils avaient déjà
accès à la la totalité du dossier je
reviens là-dessus c'est dans les
dossiers il y a quasiment tout
aujourd'hui pourquoi les délinquentss
s'adaptent parce que bah vous êtes fait
arrêter une fois vous savez comment vous
êtes
tombés et et je pense que sur certaines
techniques qui sont un peu plus
instrusives on devrait peut-être
anonymiser cela mais ça une forme de de
verrou judiciaire ce que ce qui
n'empêche pas le contrôle du juge enfin
tous les contrôles sont là je je ne
demande pas à faire des choses qui ne
soit pas acté mais euh finalement euh à
un moment trop de transparence bah nous
des armes nous-mêm